this is what's left of the vehicle used
by a group of journalists they were
struck while covering the escalating
tensions near the southern Lebanese
border with Israel reuter's cameraman
Isam abdalah was killed while aler
journalists kman Joad and Eli braia were
injured and taken to
hospital this is what happened all
journalists were here together it's a
type of safety measure this is to make
sure that both the resistance and Israel
know that we are journalists and in one
location I can clearly say that we
journalists were targeted on purpose we
were far from the confrontations the
confrontations are up this hill Over the
Horizon where the fires are this spot is
where the journalist was all of the
journalists were wearing their safety
kit they all had press slogan on their
chest and cars there was no one else
around them there was no no fighting
there was no mil there were no military
points uh the journalists were hit and
we we have so far with information that
we have they all point to an
intentionality that is difficult to
refute and in that case we are talking
about a war crime this is not the first
time Israel has targeted
journalists last year Al jaz's Shireen
Abu akle was shot dead by an Israeli
sniper in the occupied West Bank she was
clearly mocked as a journalist no one
was ever held accountable
journalists have also been killed in
Gaza in the latest escalation unions
have called for all parties to abide by
international law and protect
journalists Peter stem Al jazer